اهلا بكم في هذه النشره الموجزه افادت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه الناقواتها سيطره
على مواقع
[موسيقى]
الروسيه الى مواقع
هذا ما كان المتحدث باسم القوات
الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه الزبرجيا وخيرسون
نيف جاني ايرينا اكد تصاعد العمليات
القتاليه
جنوبي البلاد واضاف ان القوات الروسيه
تحشد قواتها باتجاه خيرسون كما ترسل
المزيد من التعزيزات عبر شبه الجزيره
[موسيقى]
كشفت القوات الروسيه وعمليات الاستطلاع
القتاليه وزادت الامدادات من شبه جزيره
القرن نحن نراقب كل حركه للامدادات
بكره
ستتخذ قرارا في وقت قريبه بشان ارسال
دبابات الى اوكرانيا بجانبها قالت وزيره
الخارجيه الالمانيه اينابرلين لن تعارض
ارسال بولندا للدبابات الاوكرانيه اذا قرر
ذلك وكان المتحدث باسم الاستخبارات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه اندريوس قد ذكر ان
بلاده ستتلقى دبابات لبرد اثنان وان
المفاوضات جاريه حاليا بهذا الشان واضفنا
بهذا هو حققت ما سماه اختراقا كبيرا في
الحصول على هذا النوع من المساعدات
العسكري
في المقابل قال رئيسه مجلس الدومه الروسي
فيات شيس لوفولوديين انها تزويده اوكرانيا
باسلحه هجوميه سيؤدي الى كارثه عالميه
واحضر المسؤول الروسي دول الغربيه وعلى
راسها الولايات المتحده من ان هذا التوجه
سيقود الى اجراءات انتقاميه باسلحه اقوى
على حد تعبيره
فقال رئيس الوزراء
الزعيم حركه ساريه درعا من منصبه وزير
الداخليه والصحه في اسرائيل كانت المحكمه
العليا الاسرائيليه قد قضت ببطلان تعيين
درعي وزيرا في الاتلاف الحكومي وطلبت منه
اقالته كونه ومدانا بالتهرب بالضرب
والسرقه وفي كتاب العقاله تعاهد نتانيه
اخر يتيح عودته الى الحكومه
في المقابل لوصف زعيم المعارضه ورئيس
الحكومه الاسرائيليه السابقه الى بيده
الحكومه الحاليه بحلبه السيرك واستنكر
لبيد وتغيب وزراء تيار الصهيونيه الدينيه
برئاسه وزير الماليه بتساليل اسمه تريش عن
جلسه الحكومه احتجاجا على تطبيق وزير
الدفاع للقانون وفقه قوله وبرز خلاف قبل
يومين بين وزير الدفاع والمليه الذي عارض
قرار اخلاقي بؤره الاستيطانيه جنوب نابلس
وتغيب عن جلسه الحكومه احتجاجا على ذلك
قال الرئيس الفرنسي من هو الماكرون انه
سينتظرون ماذا يصدر رسميا عن رئيس المرحله
الانتقاليه في بوركينا فاسو ابراهيم
تراوري بخصوص مطالبه بلاده بسحب قواتها من
هناك وقد لماح ميكرو الى وجود علاقه
بروسيا بهذا الموضوع
من التحدث فهمت ان الرسائل التي تم
تداولها في هذا شان طويل على غموض كبير هو
موجود خارج العاصمه اعتقد انه يجب الحذر
الشديد والانتباه الى ان هناك من تخصص في
المنطقه
في اوكرانيا واعني هنا اصدقائنا الروس في
التلاعبات اذا سننتظر توضيحات من السيد
تراوري في هذا الاطار
واعلن ان وجدوه طلبت من فرنسا بشكل رسمي
صاحب قواتها من البلاد في غضونه شهر واحده
مستمره منذ اشهر للمطالبه برحيل الجنود
الفرنسيين المتميزين شمال الشرقيه العاصمه
المتظاهرون فرنسا بعدم القيام بما يكفي
لمساعده البلاد في مواجه الهجمات
الارهابيه وبالتواطؤ في بعض الاحيانه هذا
واقله مصادر قريبه من الحكومه ان القرار
يتعلق باتفاقات تعاون العسكري مع باريس
وليس قطعا للعلاقات معها
قالت وزاره الاعلام الصوماليه ان خمسه
مدنيين حقت لوح واصيب 4 كما قتل جميع مسلح
حركه الشباب سته في هجوم على مكتب رئيس
بلديه بالعاصمه الصوماليه مقديشه وقالت
مصادر حكوميه الاجهزه الامنيه انهت
العمليه وكان مقاتل حركه الشباب قد شمه
هجوما بداوه بتفجير عاقبه اقتحام ومقر
البلديه
استضافت العاصمه الليبيه طرابلس امس الاحد
اجتماعا تشاوريا لاسراء الخارجيه العرب
لمناقشه تطورات القضيه الفلسطينيه
ومستجدات الازمتين الليبيه واليمنيه وعقد
الاجتماع في طرابلس باعتبار ليبيا ترقص
حاليا مجلس الجامعه العربيه على مستوى
الوزراء يعد تمهيديا للاجتماع الوزاري
العربي
المقرر عقده في القاهره الشهر القادم
وقالت وزيره الخارجيه الليبيه نجلاء
المنكوش ان بعض الدول تحاول تاثير سلبا
على المشهد السياسي
واضافتنا توحيد الملف الليبي مهم لمستقبل
ليبيا واستقرارها
للاسف قد يكون هناك بعض الدول التي ليس
مصلحتها ان ترى الاستقرار في ليبيا اييه
وكما قلت لك بالعمل المشترك
بالتحالف مع الدولنا الشقيقه والصديقه
والجاره والايضا البعيده التي تريد ان
تكون موجوده وتدعم مثل ما حدث اليوم في
هذا الاجتماع الناجح نكسر هذا الحاجز
ونؤكد على اهميه توحيد الملف الليبي لان
هذه مهمتك وزيره خارجيه اريد توحيد الملف
الليبي لكي هذا ينعكس على الاستقرار
الداخلي وعلى مستقبل ليبيا باذن الله
انا رئيس تركيا رجب طيب اردوغان انه
سيستخدم صلاحيته ليعلن في العاشر من شهر
مارس اذار المقبل عن تاريخ الانتخابات
العامه التي ستقام في الرابعه عشر من مايو
ايار القاضي
لرئيس الجمهوريه صلاحيه الاعلان
من مارس القادمه
من 60 يوما على الاقل من اجل الترتيب
للانتخابات في التاريخ
[موسيقى]